hello this is swipe on this week's show
changing the way you watch TV it's a
retro revolution and the force is strong
in our games review welcome to swipe
television has changed a lot over the
past few years a list of ways to watch
our favorite programs just keeps on
growing whether it's on mobile on-demand
via streaming on games consoles or on
our tablets what they're gonna look like
in a few more years well this week sky
which of course own Sky News has
launched a brand new product which
promises to revolutionize the way we
watch TV again so we've come along for
an exclusive hands-on you are looking at
Sky Q and with me is the man behind it
Andrew Olson this is a pretty big week
for you isn't it so tell us what is it
and how does it work and why should we
be so excited about it so sky Q is
really the next generation of TV it's a
whole family of products and it
reimagines how we watch our favorite TV
across all the different screens in our
lives it's something we call fluid
viewing and with fluid viewing your
favorite TV really can follow you from
screen to screen from room to room and
with our new feature called Q sync even
from place to place by saving your
favorite recordings at your table is
this the layout here so this is the new
home screen for Sky Q and one of the
great features is what we call my Q it's
a special new place at the heart of the
home screen and what it brings together
is that movie that you might have paused
to put the kids to bed and with one
click it just resumed exactly where you
are but you can already do that
continuing in the same room though why
would you why would you need to do it in
another room
so what sky Q allows you to do is to
resume that same program in any other
room on your TV
even on your tablet but why would
someone want to get this why is it so
much better than what's already out
there on the market what we found
talking to customers is that they live
their lives across all these different
screens now and so their favorite things
their most personal moments on TV are
their recordings so to be able to unlock
that and set it free from that living
room main TV and carry it across all the
screens from room to room and even to
take it on the tube on the airplane
there are already services do that
though aren't there nothing else has
ever done this with your live TV here in
the UK your live TV recording the most
personal moments of TV to bring them
away with you and one of the special
features standout features that we got
we brought all sorts of new great
content to the sky cue experience with
new partners like GQ and GoPro redbull
but what we've also done is something
great for music we know that over 1/3 of
our customers tell us that the living
room TV is the best sound system in
their home and they watch lots of music
video and also listen to radio and now
what we've allowed them to do is to take
their own music collection or Apple
music Spotify all their favorite music
and stream it to their box and play it
out to that living room TV alright
Andrew thanks for talking to us now I'm
going to bring you over here so we can
have a chat to journalist stuart miles
from POC alone he's been listening
carefully to that - is this the way TV
and viewing is headed now do we all just
want super control over everything I
think what you're thinking cross the
industry is this sense of having
everything on demand when you want it
where you want it regardless of the
device you're looking at so in a couple
of years time well everyone have this
kind of service in their homes yeah if
you look at the way the sky's evolved so
you had Skype lastin everybody could
post television that was the most
exciting thing at the time and actually
to get up and make a cup of tea or go
for a week or something in between
favorite moments now it's a case of well
I can actually just stop the button and
transfer it to a completely different
room and I think it's an evolution of
what you currently have now through a
number of different services and sky
trying to grab all of that and make it
something of their own but then
hopefully in the future add more things
to the experience like 4k you're
watching swipe still to count we look at
the rise of retro gaming but first
here's a roundup of some of this week's
other tech news
these bots were made for rocking at
least that's what their crowdfunding
campaign says the creators of this band
of robots want to make an album with
music sounding so professional no one
will be able to tell they're not human
but compress the head as they're cold
still need a vocalist so they're hoping
their Kickstarter campaign will help
raise money to build him or her if
however you prefer making the most of a
bit of peace and quiet here's a new
sleep gadget that's launched on
IndieGoGo Juve Oh slides under your
mattress and tracks your sleep breathing
and heartbeat it can also make sounds to
help you fall asleep and has a smart
alarm a video dictionary has also begun
crowdfunding and this Kickstarter
project involves a tour of Europe in a
double-decker bus the language learning
company behind it memorized plans to go
on an epic road trip with a team of
filmmakers linguists and coders
recording thousands of mini videos that
show people speaking their native
languages the clips will be added to an
app to help others learn new languages
in a moment we take a trip to the circus
in our weekly games review TV is that
the only industry that's evolved
massively in the past few years video
games have to but despite the huge
amounts of money pumped into blockbuster
titles like Call of Duty and GTA some
classic games are still proving pretty
popular
here's career gaming is seeing something
of a retro resurgence new 2d titles like
Super Mario maker are having huge
commercial success while old consoles
are being reborn through crowdfunding
campaigns some gamers are building up
vast collections of classics the owner
of this one says he does it for the
nostalgia of a mass of massive games
collection of over 4,000 games and
hundred box consoles from across about
20 different systems
well the main reasons why I paint retro
video games over new games because
they're much harder you know game
written next generation games these days
you run down the corridor chat boy
boy you know the old retro games you
have three lives you know three mistakes
and little 5 seconds could be game over
start again rich isn't alone in his love
for old consoles cartridges and
controllers events where people come to
buy and sell old games are becoming more
popular but as the demand increases so
does the value retro games are
definitely getting more expensive and
well I've noticed the rise is quite
exponential really I bought a game about
eight or nine years ago for 25 pounds
that's now going for over a thousand
pounds on auction sites there are
collectors who are driving up the price
of certain things boil by almost
hoarding them you know and it kind of
makes it harder now for someone getting
into retro gaming just to start a
collection for many systems
many classic games are available
digitally on next-gen consoles
others have been re-released for phone
or tablet and indie developers are also
well aware of this passion for the
16-bit era I think the main inspiration
for us in our game is very much in retro
games I mean two key games were pac-man
and Bomberman retro games and indie
games there are a lot easier to get into
I mean that they don't have necessarily
the the huge great storylines but they
also don't have like huge complicated
control mechanisms so they're really
easy to just jump right into and they
don't require 40 hours of play to really
enjoy most gamers will still choose the
big multimillion-pound franchises over a
return to the classics but at least
there's plenty of options if you want to
take a trip down memory lane
Chris Creegan Sky News from old games
the new ones
here's gap with his review of a few of
their latest releases Star Wars
Battlefront it's just come out and
there's a bit of a stink because there's
no single-player campaign it's all
multiplayer so you basically have to
have friends or an internet connection
to be able to play here which kind of
put a lot of people off and it did
initially put me off but actually being
able to play in these like crazy massive
actual Star Wars with like loads of
different people it's a really really
exciting thing circus an airing and I
first played this game a few years back
and it's just really really fun so it's
a kind of like platformer you jumping
around shooty type game but you're you
basically play the chubby kid who's
bought a ticket to the circus but
unfortunately you bought the wrong
ticket so he finds myself in the circus
so there's all these different sort of
enemies and things coming after you and
the style is kind of like really like
old school kind of pixel art but at the
same time feels like you know there's
old type of circus posters and things
used to get so there's a lot of stuff
like that especially the enemies take a
lot of their cues from that as well it's
a mobile game that takes place over the
course of days and it takes place kind
of in real time so you're basically in
charge of submarines and things like
diggers and you have to like put mines
down and you have all these like special
characters but you're playing with your
friends and you're making real-life
alliances so there's a lot of you know
stuff that goes on outside of the game
because
the aim is to sort of take control of
the sea and you do that by getting
alliances and taking out other players
but at any point you sort of have this
niggling feeling that maybe your best
friend is gonna turn on you because it
really makes you start to doubt
everything well that's it for this week
join us next time for more swype i'll
see you then bye bye